All right.
Enough of that, but
this idea of which
categories are best for
visual identification is a challenge for
doing this labelling.
So, let's assume for
a moment that we're going to have
some set of visual categories.
A question you might ask is,
about how many of them are there?
It's kind of a weird question to ask,
you know,
how many types of things are there?
But you know, look,
we've got a finite amount of gelatinous
stuffed between our ears, and
there's this question of sort of, how
many different labels do you deal with?
So Irv Biederman, a psychologist and
does work in cognitive vision and,
and mental models for doing vision,
back in the, in the 80s,
he came up with this number of
about 10 to 30 thousand, okay?
Now, big range, but
it's an interesting idea,
because it's also related if you take a
look at the number of nouns people know.
That is, you could ask how
many nouns do you know?
Well, it's not going to be 2 million and
it's not going to be 11,
at least I hope if you're watching this,
it's not 11.
Okay?
It's in the tens of thousands of range.
So it
gives you some idea of sort of
the scale of the recognition problem.
There are, by the way,
other types of categories other than
just sort of natural categories.
So, for example,
you think about functional categories.
So, here's a set of chairs, and yes,
you can sit in all these things,
although some of them look
like they would be kind of
stunningly uncomfortable, but they
don't really share a visual property.
So you can imagine that semantically,
in your head,
you know that they have
a certain relationship.
But from a recognition perspective,
it's not clear that the same process
that recognizes this as a chair,
should also recognize that as a chair.
Another type of category which is valid,
but not perceptually relevant might be
the sort of ad hoc categories of things
you find in an office environment.
That's a perfectly natural category.
In fact, it's even a category which you
can think about probabilistic reasoning
as biasing things.
Right?
If I tell you you're in an office,
you're much more likely
to find a stapler, right,
than to find a horse whip.
So maybe that would
bias your recognition.
But the notion of it being
a single visual category
as you can see from these objects
doesn't make a lot of sense.